if all women in london sat down or in
the world tomorrow woke up and said you
know what
we are not going to have sex with men
unless they marry us what do you think
men's going to do i mean
i guess i'm going to the store to buy a
ring no no i'm but i'm saying
do you think the marriage rates will go
up or do you think it will go down um
[Music]
but would it be equality though would it
be quality marriages or would you just
be trying to put a ring on it what's the
quality of quality marriage for me is
that a man is held to a standard by god
by a judge
by her family my family
our friends
by
um
everyone that see us that nowhere
together in a union if we're just
linking like it doesn't matter if you
see me with three other girls down the
road but if i'm in marriage now i have
kind of more of like
more to lose
yeah so you have to give the man more to
lose in order for him to be more
faithful
because
i mean and if you were to or not
okay right
it's weird because i i'm i think i'm the
person that decides whether or not we go
and be in a relationship or not
i would agree in saying that it's
normally a man it was a it's a man's
lead if a relationship goes that way
with a female i would agree with that
yeah right so in a sense and you are for
sex in terms of like um
access
what do you mean in terms of
i mean
i get what you mean so he means like
men so women control access to sex right
okay and men control access to
relationships
yeah yeah okay so if you take away your
bargaining chip from us but like for you
then we don't need to marry you we could
just have sex with you until we're 80.
like do you know what i mean i i could
go on uber and get food i could
get someone to come and clean my house
i could have casual um sex with with
women that want to have casual sex
because they want to be independent so i
mean like why do i need to sit down now
and give a ring and risk half of my
wealth or like my kids taken away or why
would i risk that why would i even get
married to you but why are you getting
married only like for sex like because
with sex my love it's not just for
pleasure it's for having kids so if you
want the next generation of kids to come
yeah you want them structurally coming
under a two-parent household whereas the
mom and the dad
and or sorry or like a woman and a woman
or a man and a man sorry guys
but it's under marriage where it's under
law and like so there is
marriage is hundreds of years old like
we didn't just crack the code of
marriage the other day like we no we
know what the benefits of marriage are
so like
okay
you would look you would you would be
looked upon badly in back in the days if
you left the marriage
right yeah you would do you know what i
mean yeah you would so it's like
we don't even take marriage for the same
like
so just let me just go back to um
something that somebody said earlier i
can't i can't remember who it was with
someone said that there's a lot of men
that are not getting
women right so like you have the you you
said the 90. it's a 1910 rule right so
if you got the 9010 rule 90 of the men
sorry 90 of women
i would say 80 but 80 of women want 20
of them in yeah in the world which is
why women are always fighting over men
so
because there's a there's a huge chunk
of men that women are missing
like you said they're invisible men the
invisible man there are men out there
that women don't even
they don't even look at however the
average man which which is what he is
yeah doesn't get any play his dm's are
dry yeah he
he's probably social a little bit
socially awkward he doesn't really know
how to talk to women whereas women as
you know you guys can walk out of your
houses in your jogging bottoms with a
bonnet on and still get male attention
right men average men don't don't get
that right the average woman can
actually do that right so
would you say that that is making a lot
of those average men angry
definitely i feel like they're not just
angry they're kind of like
they're kind of seeing it as like
there's nothing really there for them
anymore so
that's that's going to lead to them
having to move away like you brought up
earlier men moving away
because most men are not well i think
half of the population of men probably
over do not have any children
they don't have children whereas you
know the men that are actually breeding
with women
are breeding more than one woman
generally if you ask a man if he's got
more than one baby mother yeah so the
women are now
choosing
the guy there's something about that guy
no matter if he's got two three four
baby mothers there's something about him
that other women always choose to breed
with him and there's a whole subsection
of men in this world now who are looking
at all of that and they're thinking
when's my turn yeah that's women
cheating
say again that's women cheating so
they're cheating the game so
as i said a man is decision to for the
relationships so a lot what a lot of
women do is they force the relationship
upon the man
you have no control whether or not a
woman has
i'm just processing and listening okay
okay go ahead don't process you go yeah
i was gonna say for my point earlier
about um
marriage obviously you know it's better
to
raise a kid with more people you know it
takes a village as they say yeah and it
really does like even if you just have
two parents like
you need more than the two parents to
really raise a kid but my point is is
like you shouldn't be getting married
only for sex
like i wouldn't want to be married just
because like oh i'm good like it's not
just oh okay it's hard for me to just to
understand to you um
for me to explain to you what sex means
to men it's different to women like you
wouldn't you would never understand what
sex means to a man
you just wouldn't yes it's not just the
sex
because it's exclusive sex as well it's
um what kind of sex as well is
how how she like i don't think any man
just marries a woman just for sex
but i would say that sex is highly up up
there and one of the things that he's
looking for
so i think i think i think the statistic
out there that says the less men have
sex or society has sexless men sometimes
the more aggressive that society can
become
because men are not
expelling and expressing that sounds
right
right so
um there was a guy last year called jake
davidson i don't know if you heard of
him he's a guy who
is in plymouth he went on a rampage
right killed people did you hear about
that my hometown oh really oh so you
heard about it
i don't read it right okay but not the
best when you look at his like last
videos that he made
he turned he went from red pill like i
said that whole red pill thing and he
just went
he was in a rage because he was so upset
he didn't get any play from women he
didn't have any sex his life was boring
and he just said you know what
i'm gonna let the world know and he took
it he took a gun and he killed like five
people
in the town were they like oh woman or
is it like
um i think a man got i definitely think
a man got killed but
i think it was his parent was his
parents he was parents a child a dog and
the dad that was with the child i
believe right was it murder suicide or
just like yeah then he killed himself
afterwards
but that's crazy though but my only
thing is
why is it a woman's problem because also
like in the 80 20 thing um sure
women are more sought after in that
sense no no no
no
the 20 man is more so after
you beautiful women are everywhere you
don't find a six foot seven foot
tank guy that makes a lot of money that
knows how to talk to women that's the
best sex you've ever had in your life
these guys don't just walk around like
everywhere like do you know what i mean
it's more it's more it's rarer to find
that kind of guy so that's why it
happens because you might not move to
that guy but there's another pretty girl
that would move to that guy and then
while he's trying to sort out his issues
with her there's another girl that's
moving to him and then there's another
one and then he goes out to the club and
there's another four and then he's like
oh i forgot about
kyriana i forgot about letitia there's
another two coming then there's another
three then it's like well i'm just
getting so much casual sex so much
casuals i could turn on the tap or turn
it off whenever i want
and it's
it hurts girls when when it's that
position because they don't like to
chase
girls hate to chase man